[Musique]
un soir de la seconde guerre mondiale
winston tueur dîner avec trois de ses
ministres lors du repas les sirènes
retentissent un bombardement aérien
commence sur londres la situation est
habituel tout à coup churchill se lève
se dirige vers la cuisine demande à son
personnel de prendre les restes du repas
de les apporter à la salle à manger puis
de descendre
séance tenante à la cave pour se mettre
à l'abri les quatre hommes continuent de
dîner quelques minutes plus tard une
bombe explose et détruit complètement de
cuisine brésil sao paulo 1988 j'ai 15
ans nous rentrons d'un week-end à la
plage je suis à l'arrière du véhicule
familial
un orage se déclare c'est la routine en
était souvent le cas des trombes d'eau
s'écrase sur la route
soudainement mon corps ce temps mon
ventre se nouent et contre août contre
toute attente
j'éprouve le besoin de détacher ma
ceinture de sécurité et de m'allonger
quelques secondes plus tard la voiture
fait un aquaplaning quitte la route et
dévalé un ravin
dès le premier tonneau mon corps bascule
au sol il reste coincé entre les sièges
arrière et les sièges avant six tonneaux
plus tard la voiture est complètement
explosé à l'arrière les vitres sont
exposés et moi je suis indemne on
apprendra plus tard que cette route est
surnommée la route de la mort qui parmi
vous a déjà ressenti cette sensation
intérieur que quelque chose va se
produire
qui parmi vous a déjà ressenti ce
sentiment diffus est prégnant que
quelque chose va arriver mais sans pour
autant avoir d' indices extérieur qui ne
laisse présager de quoi que ce soit qui
connaît quelqu'un qui a eu ressenti un
vif sentiment de joie ou un soudain
malaise confirmée par
un coup de fil quelques minutes plus
tard annonçant une bonne ou une mauvaise
nouvelle
en fait ces témoignages on s'en rend
compte sont légions du traverse les
époques les cultures les mémoires mais
qu'est ce qui se cache vraiment derrière
ces expériences troublantes
est ce qu'on ne peut parler que de
coïncidence ou encore de loi du hasard
ou simplement de probabilité où at-on
réellement cette capacité à ressentir
les événements avant qu'il n'ait lieu
alors on a deux chercheurs dean radine
de l'université du nevada et dick birman
de l'université d'amsterdam qui furent
les premiers à étudier la question
ils menèrent une série d'expériences en
laboratoire pour savoir si le corps
pouvaient détecter et exprimé à l'avance
des situations du futur
rien que ça autrement dit ils eurent
l'étranger géniale idée d'étudier le
pressentiment présente iman qui
définissent comme cette vague impression
de quelque chose va arriver mais sans
avoir clairement conscience de ce que
cela peut être pour ses études
les chercheurs se sont appuyés sur une
notion bien connu depuis le 19e siècle
en psychophysiologie que l'on appelle la
réaction d'orientation cette réaction se
produit lorsque nous sommes face à un
événement qui est émotionnellement
impactant par exemple un danger une
menace ou une situation excitante
lors de cet événement de ces événements
de ces situations
notre système nerveux génèrent des
réactions physiologiques
caractéristiques par exemple les
pupilles se dilatent le rythme cardiaque
s'accélère
le flux sanguin quittent nos extrémités
pour aller vers le coeur ces changements
corporels nous permettent de mieux
réagir à optimiser en fait nos réactions
par exemple être plus présent à lutter
plus efficacement ou à détaler aussi
vite que possible
ce que faisait si bien nos ancêtres
préhistoriques
lorsqu'il se retrouver nez à nez avec un
tigre à dents de sabre
alors face à ce constat les chercheurs
se sont dit ok si l'effet pressentiment
existe vraiment tous ces signaux qu
alexis a expliqué devrait se manifester
avant même que la situation
n'apparaissent que la situation
impactante émotionnellement
n'apparaissent alors comment ils ont
fait pour déclencher cet effet
pressentiment en laboratoire ils sont
allés chercher un gros tig bien méchant
ils ont collé des grosses dents vient
bien légumes et non non c'est pas ça pas
du tout en fait ils ont procédé comme ça
sans vous en rendre compte vous venez de
vivre un peu de choses près ce que des
personnes ont vécu lorsque l'expérience
a été menée réellement en laboratoire et
les résultats vous allez le voir sont
réellement étonnant dans cette
expérience
chaque personne donc je sais sujet de
l'expérience était miss face à un
ordinateur qui tirait au hasard au sort
des images qui étaient soit
émotionnellement neutre comme un lieu
soit émotionnellement impactante
violentes comme des chocs des accidents
des images de guerre soit des images
emotionnellement pack tente mais de type
érotique là on n'a mis qu'une salle
c'est sûr pour garder votre attention
dans ses expériences donc les images
étaient tirés au sort
le sujet donc vous et moi qui se trouve
devant un ordinateur avec branché sur la
main gauche
des capteurs ces capteurs mesurent en
fait trois fonctions physiologiques le
flux sanguin au bout des doigts
l'activité électrodermale qui est la
mesure de la transpiration et le rythme
cardiaque
donc chaque personne est devant son
ordinateur et puis l'enregistrement de
ses caractéristiques physiologiques
commence quand elles le souhaitent
la personne clique cette fois ci avec la
main droite sur la souris est alors
démarre cette seconde et après ses sept
secondes pendant lesquelles l'écran
reste vierge
une image est tirée au sort et seulement
à ce moment là
cette image émotionnellement impactante
ou émotionnellement neutre à paris elle
reste affiché trois secondes pendant
lesquelles la personne peut la voir
cette image l'image disparaît ensuite et
pendant 10 secondes
l'écran vierge la personne sa vie donne
le temps de revenir un état
emotionnellement neutre une fois que
c'est fait chaque sujet cliquer et
relance 40 fois pour lui-même
le cycle et ceci pour les 24 personnes
qui ont participé à l'expérience
alors que donnent les courbes
d'enregistrement des capteurs et bien
quand la personne n'a réellement devant
ses yeux l'image perturbante
émotionnellement impactante la
conductance de sa peau augmente le
système nerveux réagi jusqu'ici tout est
normal
et quand la personne à devant ses yeux
une image paisible neutre il ya
quasiment pas de changement là aussi
tout est normal
maintenant ce qui nous intéresse c'est
ce qui se passe bien entendu avant que
n'apparaisse l'image donc dans les deux
types dans les deux cas d'image en fait
le corps près réagi le corps anticipe le
système nerveux réagit on observe qu'il
y à une conductrice de la peau qui
augmente pourquoi parce que la personne
le cobaye a peur de se prendre en face
une charge émotionnelle encore une
particulièrement gore et flippante face
à une photo d'accidents de topsy c'est
normal c'est un peu comme si on vous
proposait de jouer au jeu du marteau
alors alix il va me servir de cobaye
voilà donc voilà je vous explique je
vous propose de jouer au jeu du marteau
et je vous dis un coup sur deux je tape
un coup sur deux je tape pas mais alors
de manière complètement aléatoire c'est
à peu près l'expérience que vous avez
vécue
bah quand vous êtes fait taper une
première fois dessus car ikaika et vous
comprenez que ça fait mal donc vous avez
pas du tout envie que ça se passe comme
ça donc votre corps hop est prêt réagi
comme anticipe donc ici aussi tout est
absolument normal sauf que cette
réaction est beaucoup plus forte qu'en
l'image qui va s'afficher
émotionnellement impactante que
lorsqu'elle est neutre ceci signifie que
quand l'image qui va s'afficher aller
impactante ou quand elle est neutre
en fait notre corps en amont près réagit
déjà de la même manière ce qui veut dire
que et ça c'est vrai pour pour tous en
fait tout notre corps ce qui veut dire
que notre corps en permanence est en
train de scruter notre avenir
aujourd'hui il ya des dizaines
d'expérience qui ont été menées sur le
sujet sur le pressentiment de par le
monde dans différents labos
universitaire et toutes les mesures qui
ont pu être faites sur le corps que ce
soit différents organes les différentes
fonctions physiologiques
donc la transpiration le rythme
cardiaque le rythme cérébrale aussi vous
connaissez le fameux code feeling le
ressenti des tripes
donc ça c'est l'estomac et les intestins
qui ont des micros réaction des
micromouvements tout ça ça a été mesurée
et on montre que c'est tout le corps en
fait qui c'est tout le corps qui pré
réagi et qui nous le dit en 2012 20 une
chercheuse du liamone bridge
neuroscientifique de l'université
d'illinois qui a été la première à mener
une analyse synthétique de tous ces
résultats et ce qu'elle montre c'est
exactement ceci c'est à dire que peu
importe là on va regarder ce qui se
passe dans notre corps eh bien on montre
que l'on sait pourquoi nous n'avons nous
pas conscience que c'est en train de se
passer en continuant nous est ce que on
est trop distrait pour prendre
conscience de ces réactions spontanées
et donc ça sera difficile de les
reconnaître ou est-ce que ces réactions
sont en fait trop discrète pour qu'on
puisse les reconnaître qu'elle soit
reconnue
alors on a les deux cas en fait on a les
deux cas mais jamais entendu quelqu'un
s'exclamer ouhlala j'ai les pupilles se
dilatent je vais je vais annuler mon vol
d'avion là ou encore vos maris fans de
loterie s'exclamer chéri j'ai l'âge et
la conductance de ma peau qui ce qui
s'emballe je vais aller jouer au loto
non à côté de ces micro reflex facile
peut peut facilement détectables on a
heureusement pour nous et si on est à
l'écouté de soi même des signaux plus
facilement détectables plus facilement
conscientisent abl par exemple richard
branson se fie à l'excitation qu'il
ressent pour valider un projet conrad
hilton lui ce fut un déclic intérieur
pour savoir qu'une décision est juste
alexis écoute plutôt il a une à une
sensation d'avancer et de sentiment de
légèreté moi je les dois qui picote et
une chaleur qui m'envahit c'est comme ça
c'est cette conscience de savoir comment
ça se passe en nous qui nous a notamment
permis de pressentir la victoire de la
france à la coupe du monde de football
et de parier bien en amont quand la cote
était vachement importante donc bien en
amont d'elle
adjoints ont personnellement avec
l'argent que j'ai gagné j'ai pu payer
une partie des vacances acheter un
poulailler et le chien vous regardez les
poules alors comme vous l'aurez compris
ces réactions spontanées sont
différentes selon chacun et vous comme
nous vous avez les vôtres
à vous d'être attentif d'en prendre
conscience de les repérer et de les
valoriser
c'est alors en étant de plus en plus
attentifs à ce qui se passe en vous que
vous allez développer la connaissance
intérieur vous allez développer
l'apprentissage est alors de faire de
cette capacité naturelle qui est en nous
un outil utilisable au quotidien que ce
soit pour faire de grandes choses comme
sauver des vies ou alors des petites
choses de la vie de tous les jours en
voici un exemple paris ou 2014
marie estelle et moi on s'est donné
rendez vous devant la fnac des champs
elysées pour ensuite aller à l'aéroport
direction l'irlande et rencontrer un
confrère la veille
je me dis tiens ce serait sympa de nous
offrir un cadeau à l émoi en lien avec
le voyage pour fêter l'occasion et sans
analyser ces importants sans analyser ce
qui pourrait lui faire plaisir ou faire
plaisir et en écoutant mes ressentis
j'ai fait défiler j'attends les idées
laisser venir les idées et à ce moment
là m'est venue cette idée d'un carnet de
notes et pile poil se déclenche ce
ressenti caractéristiques
cette légèreté et cette sensation
d'aller de l'avant et je sais à ce
moment là que ce carnet de notes c'est
ça le cadeau je me dis ok demain je vais
aller acheter deux carnets de notes des
carnets de notes moleskine en lien au
voyage malheureusement le lendemain
j'arrive tellement en retard devant le
magasin que marie estelle est déjà là
vous ai compris hein c'est cuit
j'aimerais le lendemain j'ai tellement
d' avance
parce qu'à l'époque j'habitais en suisse
que du coup je me dis tiens je vais
aller à la fnac je vais aller faire un
petit tour en attendant alexis et va je
me balade dans les rayons je suis attiré
par un portique coloré j'y vais je fais
tourner et là hop cette sensation
particulière picotements dans les doigts
qui m'a l'air qingli tiens c'est
intéressant prend un objet prend un des
objets j'en prends un je vais à la
caisse pour payer et finalement je me
ravise je vais vite en prendre un
deuxième
que je paye je sors et je vois alexis
est là quand j'arrive à marie estelle
elle est déjà là elle m'offre me tiens
je vais t'offrir un cadeau et je la vois
mettre sa main dans sa besace des sortir
devinez quoi
incroyable deux carnets moleskine et pas
n'importe lesquels alors nous avons tous
cette capacité de percevoir ce qui vient
à nous notre corps vielle pressentiment
le sentiment intuitif de l'avenir on
peut l'appeler comme ça nous montre que
nous sommes tous interconnectés que nous
sommes connectés avec nos présent nos
passés nos futurs et que de ce fait on
peut se créer un avenir d'une infinie
richesse en commun la prochaine fois que
vous avez à prendre une décision à
choisir une orientation a rencontré une
personne
fermez les yeux respirez profondément et
écouter simplement comment ça fait en
vous c'est un outil simple c'est facile
accessible gratuit et qui peut
réellement vous permettre de transformer
vos rêves en réalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]